we're gonna talk about the most
anticipated ps4 games of the good year
of our Lord 2017 our lord two thousand
yeah praise be to 2017 there's a bunch
coming out that i need to bring p down
for because i'm not gonna play these I'm
just kidding i'll try to play them yeah
so there are a few that we haven't
mentioned that what about an xbox and pc
but of course they're multi-platform
games want to spread them out we'll
start with those red dead redemption too
it's not a ps4 exclusive at all but it's
one that a lot of people are excited for
any time rock star releases something
it's a big deal we did that whole live
stream event to watch the trailer the
trailer is more of a teaser it didn't
show too much showed this gang of seven
people the obvious comparison being like
magnificent seven or something they're
writing across what you had said would
be kind of the original maps northeast
section and then I up through the
Rockies so it'd be more Midwest it
seemed like it yeah seems I want more
lush right like more wild well the map
the map leaked and it really is it's
like if you continued from the northeast
of the original games map up that's what
red dead redemption to is so just going
toward the Rockies I guess who knows
what's gonna happen there all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] happens Iraqis horse race on
fights so Buffalo bison are here have
been killed off yet that's my favorite
shot there's no it looks like more cold
weather I think we did like a what we
want from red dead redemption to and my
you know this is never gonna happen
thing but I still want anyway was grand
theft auto 5 s character swapping the
zooming out and zoom back in on Franklin
Michael or Trevor but with seven people
and one gang what you're gonna need that
live via they need that um you don't
need that many people in Ocean's eleven
you don't need me that many people in
Magnificent Seven you don't need that
many people in hateful eight but they
did it anyway which I'm a movies or
video games movies but we could talk
about video games you didn't need that
many people in grant thats out of 53 was
alright like was just enough on 7p d
hotel like that at lockdown at four he
didn't need other people but school ID
so fun I think I'm more inclined to
think though and that's the other thing
we talked about was that it's an online
component we're like you and seven
buddies get on your horses yeah and your
venture yeah oh yeah like the cops and
robbers kind of stuff in Grand Theft
Auto 5 would work
84 red dead redemption yeah cops and
robbers yeah I use outlaws and eat
dennys even just grant a bottle on wash
right even just grand theft auto online
like premise currently makes more sense
in the wild west right like the biker
gangs with horses yeah but just you know
having it be you know a ruthless
unorganized on policed part of history
opposes likes a whole city it just lets
on fire yeah not la isn't already but I
don't is it I was just saying I'm not
even know I've just like I would love to
just you know walk into the street turn
around see like Rob's character staring
at me okay and has come gone I look just
like the gang from clockwork orange the
bowler hat and white onesies and
overalls underwear over it then you
approach me go back to the bar drink
milk afterward mm-hmm um no anyway that
would be great to see kind of some sort
of yeah like you said kind of like
cohesive cooperative experience where
you can form gangs and roam around it
would seem weird not to based on what
they've done with grand theft auto 5 the
biker gang update maybe you were saying
you even thought that's like kind of a
test subject to maybe do it in red dead
redemption too yeah I'm not that far but
might be kind of you know just proof of
concept I mean great to throttle online
is the reason why you don't have
single-player TLC right like it's a
success like they made a lot of money
and they will continue to so just make
sense to test those waters with other
ideas yeah looking forward to it
definitely we're talking about like
where this story might go you're gonna
be it did look like it was John Marston
and uh was one of those characters and
then I bill the rest of his gang that
you're hunting down the beginning the
first game seems like they're gonna be
incorporated somehow maybe it's did we
discover his a prequel or not that was
just based on the fact that he it must
be a preview or a prequel if like those
characters we mentioned are all together
as a gang right because you see shots of
him on a ranch which I guess you presume
even from the vo that it's his I think
meaning maybe that's this is what these
events make him spiral down until yeah
who he was in the first game yeah who
knows looking forward to that also
horizons
dawn which would be februari release
Frederick's kind of pact it's Yakuza
zero is Valentine's Day for Honor's
Valentine's Day verizon horizon zero
dawn i forget what exact day it is but
they're all februari it's kind of loaded
no no no I'm sorry Yakuza is genuinely
forth with resin evil which will also
talk about as Nemo right now horizon
zero dawn looks pretty cool it seems
like far crying third person to me were
you hunting robot dinosaurs yeah but
hopefully the robot aspect is something
fresh yeah right hey there's a lot of
opportunities there for you did
mix-match parts and create weapons and
find vulnerabilities in the different
robots which you know the game looks
really impressive but that aspect is
definitely the thing that has me the
most interested there there must be some
sort of in-depth crafting that would
make sense because like it seems like
you're trying to survive at least one
like under the watchful gaze of these
huge robot cyborg dinosaurs it make
sense to actually like gather parts from
them to craft new things because they
showed some parts where she's usually
using primitive weaponry kind of like
you know like more Stone Age kind of
stuff a Bronze Age and whatnot but then
there are later things I showed or it
looks like she was kind of you know
making use of her environment a little
more which that would be an interesting
aspect to me but the overall like kind
of cascading waterfall structure of
quests as far as there were those like
brontosaurus that once she packed it or
something along those lines or at least
a ancient version of it it looks like it
opened up a new area of the map so maybe
it's like the watchtowers from Far Cry
but kind of roaming around I I hate to
keep comparing it to far cry but these
things when she climbed up this and like
hacked into it looked like it revealed
part of the map nearby it's like Treecko
you just climb on top of his head jump
to the next area yeah we worries on my
last guardian earlier on the few
segments I don't know speaking of heads
I love that like USS Enterprise Connect
it's just like such a like we're doing
it it's such a weird blend of like I'm
just like Stone Age and futuristic
robots it's awesome like I think that's
what captivate our attention at first
but i'm hoping the story there is really
good because they've kind of hinted at
it but we don't really have that much to
go on at the moment yeah the demos we
played that we're just dropped into
smaller kind of sandbox areas i think
scott and jake both playing
I haven't played yet looking forward to
it kinda at this point I'm eyes let's
wait for the full game but regardless it
looks interesting yeah i just mentioned
it Yakuza 0 the prequel to the first
Yakuza yes okay so you are Yahoo's a fan
yeah I sort of been admiring from the
sidelines for a while I played some of
the one of them on PlayStation 3 but
yeah like it's it's a it's such a
strange series because it there's like
two halves there's like the really goofy
ridiculous wacky half that plays like
kind of like a like a like a little bit
of a shoddy arcade game but it has its
charm because it's not really meant to
be that that like involved right you're
basically just bashing heads and like
beating people up and really grotesque
funny ways and then you have this other
half with these really serious you know
cinematic story moments that are
inspired by by Yakuza films and it's
just him it's just a really interesting
mishmash because you can you can
appreciate it for what it is in both
ways right like the game knows that it's
being like dumb and silly when it's
being dumb and silly so you decide that
you have to forget it it's just that you
you pivot and you play a different game
for a minute until you get to the next
story beat and the series has done a
great job of that so far so interesting
to see you know how zero sort of sets
everything up yeah because then yeah
just six releases 2018 correct right and
then we're also know yeah and then we're
also getting yeah kazoku ami at some
point which is the remake of the
original there's a lot of yocks of games
coming which is awesome because for a
while it didn't look like we were gonna
get these there is one that we will
probably never get called Yakuza Ishin I
think our Easton it's set in like 80
Japan and okay i don't think we're
eating at that one you'll be reviewing
Yakuza zero when it releases in January
you know it cool I never play nato's i
play dead souls a little bit dead souls
which is like way different spin off
right yeah wage I'm you have guns in
that right yep yeah you don't know these
games guy Peter was showing me clips of
yeah cuz a zero and what sold me was the
karaoke just walk in and just like dish
out some songs get out and yeah continue
on yeah it looks up it just looks so
great I
it's actually this game is so similar to
Shenmue that I feel like people need to
kind of forget about Shenmue 3 for a
while and just focus on yo cuzzo because
what is Shenmue 3 gonna be it's really
hard to put your finger on it but we
know what Yaga's is going to be it's
it's taking that sort of open world
formula that it actually and it's made
by sega it's published by Sega I mean it
looks so similar to Shenmue in that
regard like the way the world looks and
how you interact with people and it's
filled with things like arcade games and
UFO catchers and all this stuff that you
can do just to [ __ ] off and have fun in
the world yeah yeah maybe that'll be my
life first full yok is a game who knows
it's also the same days resin evil which
I want talk about residen evil sorry
pretty sick this week res evil 7
biohazard I played about four hours of
it recently for a demo at capcom japan i
can't say enough good things based on
that demo i think i played about a third
of the game they told me so I have
another or a third or a quarter but I
also kind of Bruce through it because I
I just played res evil remake and again
this is like remake in first-person
almost in also screams I'm plus I'm
really [ __ ] good at video games
that's also a factor I can't wait for
this between being on PS VR and being
able to swap between P SVR and regular
you know standard watch playing on a
screen that seems luring within the same
play through the fact that save rooms
are returning there's more you know
survival saving your bullets deciding
whether to craft health packs or bullets
the fact that a lot of the you know the
Baker family is kind of chasing you this
Jack Baker behind you with shovel right
now people watching it's sent this
mansion this like it's an old-school
Louisiana plantation a defunct
plantation but this you know
cannibalistic families chasing you it
just looks like you know that the Capcom
has been saying forever and we were
saying earlier on the show a lot of
developers are going back to their roots
kind of whether it be with Zelda breath
of the wild or doom or res evil it seems
like a lot of them are kind of getting
in touch with what made the series that
they're working on great to begin with
this seems like it's an exemplar of that
and I can't wait to play more of it it
was pretty tense but it was also the
puzzle solving was there in spades but
also getting keys to go through certain
rooms kind of you know like walk through
them yeah that wall just crumbled as be
nice yeah good barely walk through it ya
mind me I'm just a powerhouse there
right there is some really goofy
justification for that
in the game i will tell you but i won't
spoil it and then you know the the story
structure between you're in this mansion
as ethan looking for your wife or
ex-wife mia she's been here for a while
and you're trying to figure out what
Marguerite and Jack Baker have done with
her and there's Lucas as well as songs
of the Graham I forget her name but
you're really getting to know these
deranged characters while you're
navigating the grounds and I already
like the layout of this mansion is
already burned into my brain and I
haven't even seen all of it because I
didn't get like the Scorpion key or
whatever I needed on like the last three
doors it just feels like a classic
resident evil but you know with modern
sensibilities obviously first person is
a big deal for Resident Evil game but I
can't wait for this this will be January
24th as well did you guys get the chance
to play any of this yet Rob you played a
couple damn here you both play a couple
demos beginning our in the lantern them
alive then the updated beginning our to
be the midnight demo okay yeah and I
played just the lantern demo on VR and
morrissey footage the more I think like
[ __ ] I might have a heart attack if I
played a whole gang like NVR like I
don't know man i feels good because you
you just ain't just feel good look yeah
wherever you want to shoot when you have
weapons it's like people kind of give
the arguments with the Crouch mechanic
[ __ ] when you just snap to but I turn it
off and like the actual act of crouching
down the camera moving maybe actually
kind of sick I don't really get motion
sick never this game like snapping to it
made it much better even though it
doesn't look real but yeah yeah I know
things aside you can customize a lot of
that in PR for a PSP are for a table 7
yeah but I'm a huge advocate for that
game I mean I'm there are some people
who are stronger will than I I know that
but like it is something cool to be said
as far as being able you know you're you
know you're being chased so I was
looking for you with the lantern and
you're being able to like you know peek
through the actual walls and do all
these really like intricate like as far
as looks and movements so that like I
think really like made it more immersive
and scary yeah i talked about res evil 7
a lot between like podcasts and just
previews and lobby
discussions and i can't wait for it i
can't say enough about the time i took
to play it and i'm looking forward to it
but Pete persona 5 hmm I'm not a
personal fan I don't have any reason not
to be I just haven't played them tell me
why I should be excited 45 should or
should I I think that you should I so I
really like the shin megami tensei games
which are sort of an offshoot of her I
guess personas an offshoot or shin
megami tensei and persona 4 was a sort
of a an RPG that everyone loved right
but five seems to be delving a little
bit more into like darker themes right
for was very much about slice-of-life
type things this game is set in Tokyo
and these kids sort of like wake up to
these alternate personalities they have
called personas you sort of like
supernatural our alter egos and they
delve into this like another world to
deal with like adults that have like
horrible like immoral motivations and
they try to like quell that and like
this game deals with a lot of like
personal and social issues but then it
presents it with this like bright poppy
really stylish exterior so I think it's
just got like a lot of things going for
it both in terms of you know the
narrative the way it looks and then the
combat as well which is a mix of sort of
like you know people with guns but also
their supernatural counterparts and is
it its turn based combat correct yeah
that's what I assumed but yeah looking
forward to it I'd still in play personal
for that's been on my list for like five
years game is also like a hundred hours
long I think you can safely wait and
just play this all right yeah what did
that another one that you just played a
few minutes ago anything near auto Mata
yeah so the sequel to the 2009-2010 cult
classic this is even a sequel it's a
following said it's it's got a subtitle
but near was 2010 cult classic just kind
of this I don't know weird open-world
RPG with questionable action mechanics
so to correct that with auto Mata they
brought in platinum games who's also
working on um you know the works i like
your rising they're working on
scalebound right now yeah they also did
you know metal gear rising revengeance
and bayonetta but near autumn on out p
you and i both play the demo i like this
game a lot so far yeah it's got that
that platinum sort of melee combat going
on for it which
always feels great and it's got an
interesting presentation that I don't
even know what you'd categorize it as
it's sort of like gothic j-pop meets
metal gear kind of yeah I guess so
you're these androids sent down from the
moon where humans escape to when robots
took birth yeah except battle the robots
yeah clear it for humans to come back
but as you can see here your character
has this sort of like a re little
robotic buddy floating behind her and
that sort of opens up some like arcade
shooter elements sort of in the way that
fury does as well if you play that game
where you get to go in and do close
combat with a sore but you can also fire
from afar and it all actually meshes
really well together even though the
game tends to hop around in terms of the
perspective so sometimes you're in a
side-scrolling environment other times
it's a top-down perspective and then you
have the sort of you know regular third
person like 360-degree action game like
you see here it's just a really
interesting mix of mechanics and
presentation yeah the camera work was
great from the demo I played and then it
became like a bullet hell at certain
points when you're dodging projectiles
and shooting the people are shooting at
you yet to mention that robot floating
around next year those are that's one of
the pods I believe so you get pods that
let you do these like special attacks
like that yeah schutte spears out and a
sphere around you or just surround
yourself with these shields that deflect
you know projectiles back at enemies
yeah I don't feel weird making a metal
gear comparison like especially because
the combat feels similar to rising but
there's also like an alternate skin for
that robot that is a cardboard box skin
really yeah like they're they're being
subtle about it I've in a way but
they're also not I mean I think this
game is just gonna be a great marriage
of different ideas that just happens to
have the near title yeah I don't know
why and I really can't put my finger on
it cuz the first game like it's the same
storyline and it's this is so this isn't
yeah it's the same like it's set I think
well it's set millennia and really the
first one but it's the same world same
idea of you know cyborgs being but sent
back down to earth okay the battle
robots but it's also open world which we
haven't seen I'm doing the demo the demo
is just one small bite sized chunk I
haven't fought this boss he's at the end
of the demo but they platinum stopped me
before I could finish it but yeah I
don't know it seems like platinum could
just release any game with any name and
we know it's platinum and hope for
best for the best yeah what was cool
about this game is that they're totally
embracing the the Japanese style for the
international release because the first
near they actually remodeled the
character for Western releases ok so in
the West we got this like really
barbaric ugly looking dude and in Japan
they got like a pretty looking like you
know Japanese hero type I'm excited it's
it's like I don't know I mean it's not
like a huge sticking point for me but
it's just I don't know I'm glad that
platinum can just go you know as far as
they want to and say the sort of things
a day they love yeah it's one that was
under the radar for me and then I played
a demo loved up and trying to champion
here we have a demo now wish to try it
out but I yeah so those are our ps4
games I'm sure we missed a few in like
we said they're a lot of multi-platform
owns we already talked about an xbox one
but if you mess any big ones or missing
ones that you want to mention let us
know in the comments below
you